es knallt sehr laut die erde bebt ein
riesiger leuchtender feuerwehr erhält
den himmel über dem mittleren westen der
usa und teilen kanadas die menschen
verfallen in panik handelt es sich um
eine alien invasion oder ist das jetzt
der untergang der erde
ihr habt euch dieses thema war whatsapp
gewünscht und ich beantworte alle fragen
dazu
denn solche ereignisse sind tatsächlich
eine reale bedrohung jetzt den klicks
und science fiction herzlich willkommen
es war der reinste horror für diejenigen
die diesen abend über den südlichen
michigan miterlebt haben auf twitter
hieß es für mich war klar dass ich da
entweder eine invasion von
außerirdischen oder die apokalypse
beobachtet
eine frau schrieb wir waren uns sicher
dass gerade jemand unser haus angreift
die sozialen netzwerke quellen über mit
meldungen fotos und videos der helle
feuerball erleuchtet gegen 20 uhr abends
am 16 januar für wenige sekunden den
himmel über michigan ohio und ontario
alles wirklich dicht besiedelte regionen
der wetterdienst aus ohio gab dann aber
entwarnung der knall oder fernlicht
seien nicht von einem gewitter
ausgegangen aber von was all das wurde
stattdessen verursacht von einem
mitglied der zum einen für den riesigen
feuerball am himmel sorgte nicht ganz
geklärt ist offensichtlich ob man das
objekt wohl korrekter weise als metroid
oder bereits als kleinen astro ihn
bezeichnen kann
einfach gesagt sind mit der diesen
kleiner als erst zu ihnen beim
eindringen in die atmosphäre
können sie für sternschnuppen oder in
sehr hellen feuerkugeln verursachen wenn
sie nicht komplett verglühen wird ein
meteorit zum meteorit mit tee am ende
die nasa sprich in einer offiziellen
mitteilung aber von einem kleinen
asteroiden basierend auf den neuesten
daten wurde der extrem helle licht
streifen am himmel von einem 6 fuß
breiten weltraummission einen kleinen
asteroiden verursacht er dann mit einer
geschätzten geschwindigkeit von 36.000
meilen pro stunde in die erdatmosphäre
irgendwo im südosten von michigan ein
und explodierte mit etwa zehn tonnen gmt
am himmel also er war ungefähr zwei
meter groß und knapp 60.000 kilometer
pro stunde schnell wahnsinn also aber
eigentlich ganz harmlos jedenfalls für
einen asteroiden wenn er nicht der
vorbote für etwas größeres wäre weil er
so rasend schnell unterwegs war
erschütterte die explosion sogar den
boden in der region die behörden hatten
ein seismisches ereignis mit der stärke
2 registrieren dazu der erdbebenforscher
der eu von der universität michigan
das war eindeutig eine explosion in der
atmosphäre und kein erdbeben das
seismogramm zeigt deutlich die
unterschiede zu kleineren regionalen
erst sehen es könnte also zu einem
anschlag gekommen sein einige zeit nach
der horror nach verkündete ein suchtrupp
stücke gefunden zu haben und zwar in
einem see in michigan dass die erde von
meteoriten getroffen wird ist kein
seltenes ereignis experten sind sich
einig um solch ein sicht- und hörbare
spektakel wir haben 16 januar zu
verursachen muss es sich um objekte
handeln die mindestens einen durchmesser
von einem meter haben
dies passiert dem forschungsteam aus
michigan zufolge alle paar monate laut
nasa fängt die erde täglich rund 18
tonnen ja weltraum material ab zum
großteil winzige teilchen deren
durchmesser nicht mal einen millimeter
beträgt für die nasa selbst ist ein
solches ereignis von mitte januar kaum
der rede wert denn die explosion von
tscheljabinsk von 2013 sprach rund
58.000 tonnen dmt und sorgte für knapp
1500 verletzte und gesperrte fenster in
sechs städten auch hausdächer und autos
wurden beschädigt laut nasa wurden
allerdings noch nie menschen von einem
meteoriten getötete glücklicherweise
wurde das ganze phänomen mitte januar
von vielen verschiedenen kameras und
sensoren von verschiedenen standorten
aus aufgezeichnet dadurch versprechen
sich die forschungsteams mehr
informationen zu der größe und der
flugbahn des objekts zu bekommen das
planetary die fans koordination office
der nasa hat das hat es vor allem auf
große asteroiden abgesehen kleinere
objekte werden da er schnell
übersehen und sind auch nicht so
interessant und diese einheit hatte die
usa ihr letztes jahr eingerichtet um
erdnahe asteroiden zu entdecken und zu
verfolgen denn die können uns ziemlich
gefährlich werden ja und die größeren
sogar gelten als auslöser von
massensterben auf der erde alle paar
millionen jahre steuert ein großer
asteroid auf die erde zu der das leben
tatsächlich bedroht die nasa hat
deswegen das ziel bis 2020 alle erdnahen
asteroiden die größer als 140 meter sind
zu entdecken denn genau diese könnten
der erde gefährlich werden und es gibt
wahnsinnig viele unentdeckte das zu
ihnen die gefahr ist also groß von einem
solch riesigen himmelskörper getroffen
zu werden und auch nur sehr schwer
einzuschätzen da die asteroiden auch
ihre flugbahn öfter ändern das geschieht
auch ganz ohne den vorbeiflug an
größeren planeten zum beispiel durch die
einstellung von anderen kleineren
asteroiden immer mehr
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
warnen jetzt vor dem hohen risiko eines
größeren ein start auf der erde wie oft
das in den ersten 13 jahren dieses
jahrhunderts passiert ist wurde ja vor
einiger zeit bekannt 26 asteroiden sind
auf der erde eingeschlagen darauf
gekommen sind findige wissenschaftler in
sie hatten die idee beim weltweiten
atomteststopp überwachungs netzwerk
nachzufragen ob es andere größere
explosionen auf der erde gab und es
waren 26 und es konnten nur asteroiden
einsteige sein nichts anderes hat eine
solche braucht lediglich ein einschlag
wurde dabei vorher gesehen nur einer
alle anderen kamen im wahrsten sinne des
wortes aus heiterem himmel jedes jahr
schlagen also zwei größere asteroiden
hier auf der erde ein
wie sehr hatten wir großes glück denn
die gesteinsbrocken schlugen mehr in
wüsten oder sonstigen unbewohnten
gebieten ein und verdampften bereits in
der atmosphäre
wie hoch ist also das risiko wirklich
wie schnell ein asteroid oder komet auf
einem planeten einschlagen kann das
wurde 1994 deutlich der komet shoemaker
levy ist ein beeindruckendes beispiel
entdeckt wurde haben 24 693 am 16 juli
1994 also nur gut ein jahr später
schlugen die ersten bruchstücke auf dem
jupiter ein
sie hatten eine sprengkraft achtung von
50 millionen die roscheba bomben der
jupiter hat allerdings ein deutlich
größeres und stärkeres kavitation
ausfällt als die
aber trotzdem ist das risiko auch hier
hoch millionen und abermillionen
gesteinsbrocken rasen durch unser
sonnensystem und dabei sind die zahlen
allein zu unserem planeten beeindruckend
es wird vermutet dass etwa eine million
asteoriden sich im bereich der
erdumlaufbahn befinden davon kennen wir
inzwischen immer mehr nach aktuellem
stand sind 755 1599 objekte die wir
kennen die in unserem sonnensystem umher
schritt das ist schon deutlich mehr als
noch vor ein paar jahren aber
tatsächlich sind es wohl millionen die
in unserem sonnensystem umher greifen
wir kennen also nur einen kleinen teil
und deswegen schlagen forschungsteams
seit jahren immer wieder erlauben sie
plädieren für eine bessere weltweite
zusammenarbeit und den aufbau eines
koordinierten frühwarnsystems und
wirklich effektive zur abwehrstrategien
sind noch immer nicht ausgetüftelt die
nasa arbeitet zusammen mit hochdruck
daran potenziell gefährliche asteroiden
abzulenken beispielsweise mit laser oder
raketen
allerdings müssen wir fürchten dass
einer der statistisch gesehen zwei
asteroiden jedes jahre einschlagen in
einer gegen auftritt in der millionen
menschen eben das will eine private
initiative jetzt verhindern ehemalige
astronauten um den space shuttle piloten
wollen asteroiden finden die zumindest
städte länder und kontinente zerstören
könnt und damit sie im frühzeitig
erkannt werden wollte ihre
organisationen bees 612 einen privat
finanzierten satelliten in den weltraum
schicken der der zu ihnen mit einer
wärmebildkamera findet doch die
initiative bekam das geld nicht zusammen
die nasa kündigte den vertrag zum start
des satelliten das sieht dann so
schlecht aus jetzt will die organisation
kleinere und billigere satelliten ins
weltall schicken um nicht mehr so hohe
finanzielle hürden zu haben und
raketenstarts die werden ja auch immer
billiger dankt allen masc also es könnte
vielleicht bald realität werden dieses
frühwarnsystem auf jeden fall müssen wir
handeln denn das was in michigan
passiert es wird ganz schnell eine große
katastrophe nämlich dann wenn der
assault nur etwas größer ist und in
einem besiedelten gebiet einschlägt ja
wenn er als erstes neues zu asteroiden
einsteigen und zu allen anderen themen
erfahren wollt dann meldet euch hierbei
whatsapp an dann erfahrt ihr vor allen
an
vom neuesten video eben vorab von mir
garantiert ihr könnt dort direkt mit mir
in der redaktion von pixum mitmachen und
themen vorschlagen oder andere
vorschläge machen
der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier
draufklicken und natürlich nicht das abo
mit der genau glocke vergessen dafür
unten abonnieren hier überall
ja und jetzt geht es weiter dafür auch
draufklicken sos schreibt an der erde
vorbei beginn einer neuen ära ansonsten
bis dann bleibt dran